[Applause]
g'day everybody having these talks been
amazing let's hear it for everyone yeah
I do not want to follow them but I'm
just going to State the blindingly
obvious the world is burning
it's hotter than it has ever been in
recorded history our recorded history
what's more
the last time the world was this hot
people didn't exist
that's not a good omen
the biggest problem is we know what the
solution is we just need to stop
emitting 30 gigatons of greenhouse gases
stop polluting stop rolling out
polluting Technologies just stop
well let's ask the ludites how well that
worked out for them okay stopping not a
strong point let's be radical and
embrace technology I'm team robot all
the way
with robots with drones in particular
and thermal imaging we can detect heat
leakage
particularly from old buildings which
are responsible for 99 of the heat waste
and we can't retrofit them
that's why the department of energy ran
the e-robot prize to find robots that
could go into ethics and wall cavities
and under the floor and replace all of
that insulation
it's why 3D printing is a really great
answer we're eliminating Transportation
costs and waste where reducing waste
this is Texas icon is Building 100 3D
printed homes there California Mighty
buildings but NASA had the Centennial
challenge
about six years ago
to use local
materials mud
for Mars or for our homes here but
moving on to transport a self-driving
cars tip of the iceberg just a tiny
little part of what we can achieve with
autonomous mobile robot Technologies
it's all about self-driving cargo and
these are all electric vehicles right
already at the major retailers know this
this is jd.com same thing at ocado or
Amazon or Walmart
but what's been exciting over the last
five years is the plethora
of new autonomous mobile robots roaming
out into the world you probably don't
see them but we're rethinking how we
move materials changing the first mile
changing the Last Mile and all the miles
in between and before you say well hey
electricity isn't all it's cracked up to
be right
we are introducing solar power faster
than ever before because we're using
robots to help construct
solar farms and to keep them clean
we have new battery technologies coming
this one I love it is carbon based
plant-based it is already in commercial
deployment multiple units last year and
2025 the first fully
ecosustainable battery
Alpha Garden you probably know Ken
Goldberg it's a project of his up at UC
Berkeley to show that Robotics and AI
can perform organic multi-crop tending
as well as people can
farmers are embracing robotic technology
and this is not the massive Machines of
our previous agricultural systems these
are smaller lighter
machines from the actual tractors in use
today to new devices like this lovely
little dandelion robot from France
and that allows us to get into 20 of the
arable area that is currently not
utilized and to stop the soil compaction
that is destroying our ability to use
the land
we can now do proper regenerative
practices in agriculture with the use of
robots including solar powered windsail
robots like agent just up the coast here
let us not forget
animal
happy cows
cows have been looked after 24 7 by
robots and you know what their hormone
levels show that they are happy and so
does the milk so all I can say is forget
that AI apocalypse
there is nothing that the smartest
artificial intelligence can do that
stupid humans haven't already bug it up
embrace the robots
let us save the planet with robots Okay
Viva robotopia
[Applause]